hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
capture life as it happens the new leica
nana workflow
i am jennifer woods of labruz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruts
and brought to you by leica microsystems
to learn more
visit leicamicrosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting
any questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
julia kernig
product manager em sample preparation
for cryo workflows
for a full biography on our speaker
please click on the biography tab at the
top right of your screen
dr kearney you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much jen for the
introduction and welcome everybody
to our webinar today to present you the
first commercial lifecyclem solution
our new leica nano workflow
when you work in electron microscopy you
know that a lot of workflows
start with the sample preparation itself
which can be
tedious and very time consuming
depending on the application you want to
achieve
with the leica nano workflow this
looking for the needle in the haystack
is a thing of the past
in this workflow we combine the strength
of both
light and electron microscopy to
directly identify the right cell
at the right time point
and in the end unlock the cell secret by
placing dynamic life cell imaging data
into either structural context
so what we were gonna do is we start our
sample preparation on the living
sample and image this our cells in a
living state
until they reach the moment of interest
the advantages of life cell imaging is
that we know the molecular identity
because of the floor force
we use and we have all the dynamic data
to check
that we are really looking for the
phenotype we are interested in
and that will also really um
catch the moment that is interesting for
our ultrastructural analysis
on the em side we then have the
ultrastructure
that gives us the rich context and
um the high resolution to really see in
detail
what's going on so in the end we combine
the advantages of both worlds to get a
much
more complete picture of the function
or the structure of our event of
interest
however there are four major challenges
that we would like to address with our
leica nano workflow solution
the first thing is that we need to keep
the samples in physiological conditions
at all times this means
from cell culture until
the transport to our live microscopes
during the light microscopy imaging
until the moment of freezing
in the second thing is we need to
capture fast cellular events
cellular events can depend from
millisecond range until hours or days
depending on
on the cellular event you are interested
in and we want to capture
all different types of events with the
with the specific imaging system
yeah the the third point is that we want
to obtain excellent fixation results
to really analyze the structure in high
resolution
and the fourth part is that we of course
need to retrieve the event of interest
that we
uh focused on doing in our life cell
imaging
in the electron microscope later to
really
correlate the dynamic data with the
underlying ultrastructure
and in the next slides i would like to
show you in
a little bit more in detail how we
address this
challenges in our workflow solution
this is how the leica workflow
looks like it consists of different
instruments that we
streamlined together uh to really answer
um yeah to really overcome the obstacles
i already uh
talked about the first thing is
we start with the sample preparation in
our newly designed sampling chambers
the sampling chambers are little mini
incubators
that keep the samples under
physiological conditions
from cells eating until the moment of
fixation
the sampling chambers enable a
continuous gas and
exchange to do really long
term life cell imaging until the moment
of interest is reached
it gives you in the end more time to
find the right a cell
and also the right moment the sampling
chamber enables further
very high resolution life cell imaging
that we perform in the workflow with our
newly configured thunder imager nano
the thunder imager nano is a wirecraft
system that is equipped with a
fast and seamless camera camera to
really
capture fast cellular events with the
thunder technology attached
it also helps to target
and identify structures of interest
in a high resolution furthermore
we use a specific sapphire corrected
objective i will talk later about a bit
more in detail
to get the best possible resolution for
our live cell imaging
after life cell imaging we transfer the
whole thing
in the with a sampling kit to the high
pressure freezer
to enable a fast transfer
to capture the event of interest we
we are able here to have a transfer
in less than five seconds from imaging
until the
until the moment of high pressure
freezing the transfer is very easy to
to perform in a three-step
semi-automated
movement i will also talk later a little
bit more in detail
the fixation to get the best possible
possible fixation we use high pressure
freezing
with our already established high
pressure freezer the emis
and all the benefits that come with this
system furthermore
this lifecycle solution can be um
can be also used together with light
stimulation
um to uh to enable a more
flag enable more flexibility in your
experimental setup
and the downstream sample preparation
will be then
done with our well established workflow
using the
free substitution in the amf afs
ii um the iphone my chrotomy using the
uc7
and if needed we can also do contrasting
with the ac20
in the next slide i would like to show
you some preparation
steps that need to be done to get
the lifecycle system working
the in the first step you need to
prepare the same
the sampling chamber so what we need to
do is we need to attach
the emis middle plates and assembly
and the sapphire to the sampling base
cup to enable a fast transfer
and furthermore to reuse also parts
um um of the
yeah to reuse um parts
and consumables in the second step we
have the sampling chamber
that we then uh need for cell seeding so
we seed
ourselves directly in the in the
sampling chamber
and the sampling chamber can then be
placed in a standard incubator
or into our um oxygen
oxygen transportable incubator i will
also talk in a minute about
um the third step is then incubation and
transport as i said we can then
transport our samples directly from the
incubator
to the microscope without interruption
of the physiological control of our
samples
and then in the fourth step we image the
samples
on the thunder imager nano
with the sapphire corrected um system uh
objective and in the last step then
we do the transfer in our with a
three-step semi-automated transfer
system that is directly attached
to the emis
okay now i would like to
talk you uh through some of the um
main developments of the lifecycle
system that helps you to
overcome the different obstacles
first as we discussed we need to
guarantee that the samples are
physiologically controlled
throughout the whole workflow therefore
we designed the so-called sampling
chamber
which is an open chamber design to
ensure stable physiological conditions
it has a gas inlet and outlet and is
constantly um controlled
with co2 and o2 and the temperature
this gives you the the possibility to be
really relaxed when it comes to life
cell imaging
you can do live cell imaging between
minutes
and hours without compromising the
sample quality
as you can see here with the open
chamber design we can
keep this temperature co2 and o2
control constant over a long period of
time
while when you would use a closed
chamber the
the co2 and o2 levels as well as the
temperature
would drop within a few minutes which
would give you only if
an imaging time of five minutes while in
our open design
we have the long-term imaging ability
and as i said long-term imaging is very
important
uh because of two um uh yeah
two facts one is that you need to ensure
that the cell you selected
shows the wire tie or shows the
phenotype you are actually interested in
and to judge that you need to image the
cell for
a certain amount of time to really
ensure that is the phenotype
and the second thing is if you want to
follow or if you want to
target a specific process during
a dynamic process for example mitosis
that takes
um minutes to hours depending on the
stage you are interested in
you need to follow this process from the
beginning
otherwise you can never be sure that you
really
catch the concrete moment of interest
so imaging for longer time
is very crucial for this kind of
workflow
as i said the physiological control of
the sample is
is a key factor for these kind of
workflows
and we work in this workflow together
with baker raskin who developed the
oxygeny
which is a transportable incubator
that enables the transport between labs
but also institutes
without compromising the sample it
enables multi-sample imaging because we
can have
up to six sample um sampling chambers
in this little incubator and it holds
the co2 and o2 level for up to 16 hours
with the two
gas bottles that are connected
depending on your imaging and on your
experimental conditions you can fill
these gas bottles with
any gas mixture you are interested
in so not only wire type or standard
um physiological conditions are possible
you could also
do experimental setups with low co2 or
low
o2 levels if you are interested in that
as i said we are doing our live cell
imaging with the newly configured
thunder imager nano
the image the thunder imager nano
belongs to the thunder imager family
it's a system for high throughput for
better statistics and workflow
efficiency
it gives you a higher imaging
performance
for easy-to-use instruments so also new
users
could easily learn to use the thunder
imager
for these types of applications it
keeps the optimal physiological
conditions um
to the samples and it
can do accurate time-lapse
multi-position experiments
and tracking of cell chambers so
with our setup you could also do
multiple
multiple regions on the sapphire
to have multiple samples in one run
if you want to
yeah as i said the thunder image and
narnia is a easy to use
um 3d lifestyle imaging system
and you also benefit with this system
from the
from leica's innovative computational
clearing technology the thunder
technology
that effectively removes out of focus
blur
and with that allows you a precise
targeting of the structure of interest
and as you can see here in the image on
the left side you see a standard
wirefield
image where you have a lot of background
light from from the different
planes above and below and with the
thunder
technology and this background blur
is removed that you can
see the the details of your of your
structure
more clearly and especially for these
kind of workflow this is very
interesting because it allows you to
have a
more precise targeting of your structure
of interest in the
more precise location
as i said in the beginning the thunder
imager nano is equipped with with a very
sensitive simus fluorescence camera
that allows you to capture live events
in a
in a very fast speed with a 90 frames
per second this fast speed of the camera
is not only beneficial to capture the
live
the the the the live events it it also
helps us to create
overview images of the six millimeter
sapphire
at the beginning to judge which region
of the sapphire would be perfect to
to follow uh yeah to select um a cell of
interest
on the right side you can see um
a six millimeter sapphire that
where we created an overview image in
two channels
in the green fluorescence channel but
also in
transmitted light and we did this
overview already with our 40x 1.1
and a sapphire corrected objective so
with the final magnification and
resolution
and it took us 486 um
tires to create this overview image and
imaging this in two channels took us
less than three minutes
because of the speed of the camera
as i said we are using here a specific
sapphire corrected objective
due to a very important reason
so the sapphire has different
imaging properties in comparison to
glass
so if we would use a standard glass
corrected objective
the the wavelength for example of the
green and of the red
yeah the green and the red wavelength
they
would not focus in the same
in the same focus position in in c
because of the
um of the grammatical aberration of the
sapphire
this would mean that the um the picture
in the end
would appear uh blurry and we wouldn't
be able to target very precise
with the sapphire corrected objective
the this chromatic aberration of the
sapphire is corrected so that the
different wavelengths
focus again at the same c
height inside the sample
the last thing i would like to highlight
is the transfer
mechanism as i said we use here a
three-step semi-automated
transfer uh to to
[Music]
decrease the time we need to
transfer our samples from the
light microscope into the high pressure
freezer
so we have first
a so-called slide to release mechanism
so we are sliding
the little mini incubator along
a ridge that is attached to the emi's
loading area with the sliding mechanism
the middle plate um detaches from
detaches from the mini incubator and
lays
directly into freezing roof then we have
the click to drop mechanism
where we have our lid application arm
with our closing carrier
that closes the whole sandwich and then
we use
the the already established close to
freeze mechanism of the emis
to initiate the freezing
this semi-automated transfer can be used
for left and
right-handed people and it can be also
upgraded on all existing
emis machines without
major modifications of the emis itself
i want to take one more minute to talk a
little bit about
time skills of biological processes
to put this five seconds transfer time
into a into relation
when we look at the different uh
biological processes
from very short to very long um timings
we see that the fastest fastest
events occur in a millisecond range
these events like a synaptic vesicle
fusion or
gpcr activation are not
catchable with these lifecycle
applications
anyway however here you could use the
established
emi slide and or electrical stimulation
to capture these types of events
then we have a transition phase between
one second
to five seconds which is more or less
critical for a vesicle transport
application and here it depends on your
biological question are you really
interested in the transport itself then
the five seconds a transfer time can be
a
limiting however if you're interested in
the the end result of a trend uh
transfer then we could potentially
capture this with the five
second transfer time all other um
[Music]
dynamic process like philippian dynamics
classroom
mediated endocytosis cell movements
mitosis and cytokinesis
they are more in the seconds to minutes
to our range
and are easily capturable with our
lifecyclem solution especially because
we can follow
these dynamic events from start until
the moment of interest
so i hope that i could show you that
with the new leica nano workflow we
could overcome
the obstacles that comes with livestream
experiments
like we can keep the samples in
physiological conditions at all
uh at all times thanks to the oxygenia
and our small sampling chambers we can
capture fast cellular
events with the thunder imager nano and
the
40x sapphire corrected objective
to identify and target our structure of
interest
we can obtain excellent fixation results
by high pressure freezing with our
established emis
high pressure freezer and we can
reliably retrieve the event of
interest in the electron microscope
thanks to our semi-automated
transfer mechanism and
with this i would like to thank you very
much um
for your attention and i'm looking
forward um
to our question and answer session and
with this i would like to hand over back
to jen
thank you dr kernig for your informative
presentation
we will now start with the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question is
do the high pressure freezer and the
microscope need to be next to each other
at all times
yeah thank you very much um no they
don't need to be next to each other at
all times they can be
um in different labs or in different
facilities they don't need to be on the
same floor the emis is movable so and
can be for the experiments
can be transported next to the light
microscope
and then placed back to its original
point or parking position where you can
then do your
normal or standard high pressure
freezing experiments
all right thank you dr kernick our next
question is
would the workflow work also with other
imaging systems like confocal
yes so um we
used for our experiments we used the
thunder imager
uh because of its flexibility however if
your samples require confocal imaging
you also could perform the workflow on a
confocal like our new stellaris platform
great thank you again dr kernick our
next question is
are the sam sampling excuse me the
sampling
chambers one time use
um partially so you can
reuse parts like the middle plate of the
emis
and the covers who close the little mini
incubator
however the sapphire and also the
sampling base cup
they are a one-time use and they should
be replaced after each
experiment um
maybe one more thing i would like to
mention here is we offer then also
dedicated consumable packages
um that gives you or provides you
everything that is needed
for a certain amount of experimental
runs
thanks again dr kernick our next
question i'm going to try to pronounce
everything there are some abbreviations
and i think that's what this
uh question is wanting to clarify
on the 40x object so obj
mode objective mode correct
is mentioned what does the mot or the
moat mean
something motorized on the objective yes
so
exactly the objective has on top a
motorized scoring
the curing is needed to correct
some um unevenness of the sapphire when
when sapphires are produced
then it's not so easy to have them um as
plain as
our high quality cover glasses so
having a motorized correction ring will
help you
to even the slight differences in the
thickness of the
sapphire out
perfect thank you dr kernig our next
question is
is the idea to unload the sample from
the light microscope
load it into the high pressure freezer
and freeze it all within five seconds
yes exactly that that's the idea and it
actually works
so um the five seconds account from
taking the sample
at the microscope placing it onto the
high pressure freezer and freeze it
so this we call five second and transfer
time
all right thank you again dr kernig
this person asks could you please give
additional
details of how you identify and select
the cell of interest
after freeze substitution oh yeah i'm
sorry that i
missed this point so of course um at the
first step
we have our sapphire and we evaporate a
grid pattern this is um
um yeah we evaporate a grid pattern on
top of the
sapphire this grid pattern you can see
then in the transmitted light
of the light microscope and you see it
after
um free substitution and embedding
inside
the um on top of the
resin block so what we normally do in
the workflow is then and it's also
described in the
in the application um workflow
application node
that we then do um imaging an imaging
step
of the sapphire block
on the microscope and then we overlay
the block face with the light microscope
to see that all cells are still there
and then we go on to the sectioning you
don't need to do this step
but we only want to ensure that
everything is okay that our um
our cells are still there and then do
the
the subsequent sectioning and trimming
all right thank you again dr kernig the
next question
is would drug treatment experiments be
possible
yes they are possible
with some slight modifications but
in theory there that's not a big problem
for the
workflow to also do drug treatments
great and our next question is
is the light microscopy diffraction
limited
is there any possibility of sim or
single particle
tracking what is the detector for the
light microscopy
well that's a very tricky question for
me
as a non non-expert in light microscopy
however i try to answer it as as much as
i can so
the the sapphire differs in some imaging
properties
from the from
a standard glass so it's for example
double breaking which
makes dic not possible and also stat
imaging
is not possible if now structured
illumination
is uh possible with this um sapphire i
need to
check um with my r d team and
and yeah come back with this um question
at the moment uh
we use a a cmos camera on the microscope
for imaging but i think here um we are
totally flexible as we are totally
flexible from the imaging system
you could i think also use different
detection systems
like we have it on on confocal systems
for example
all right great thank you again dr
kernick the next question is
will the objective be available
separately
uh no not at the moment so this
sapphire corrected objective is
currently only available um
with this with the leica nano workflow
and the next question here is wouldn't
it be better to have a rigid connection
of the light microscope and the high
pressure freezer to reduce the transfer
time
um that was also for us very interesting
discussion internally and in the end we
decided
not to do it because of multiple reasons
so if we would have a rigidness a
connection between the light microscope
and the high pressure freezer
we may have would save two seconds or
potentially three seconds
and transfer time however as i showed
you before
in the slides the biological relevance
between two
or five seconds transfer time is is not
very high
on the other hand if we would have this
rigid connection
it would um take the
the advantages that we have with this
workflow a way for example
we wouldn't be as flexible with the led
lab setup so the microscope and the
high pressure freezer they would need to
be next to each other at all times
and also when it comes to imaging
modalities as i said
we we showed this here with the thunder
system but it also would work on a
confocal
this this wouldn't be so easily possible
anymore
and uh also immersion imaging
physiological control
um these are all parts that are then not
as easy anymore as uh yeah
as we have it now so in the end we
decided
not to do it and have the advantages on
the on the imaging
side and on the on the sample side
all right thank you again dr kernick the
next question is
what samples can be used within the
workflow besides cells
uh yeah in theory everything that fits
in the
um in the in the in the freezing
sandwich so we use here a
cover carrier with a hundred micron
steps
and we have six millimeter um space in
diameter
of the of the sapphire so everything
that fits into the six millimeter
and is not higher than hundred microns
um should work
with this workflow
thank you again dr kernick our next
question is
how easy is it to place an
ultrastructural
snapshot in the temporal contact if you
don't have zero seconds transfer time
yeah as i um showed this already before
in the
present in the presentation the idea of
the live cycle
is that you target a particular time or
stage
of a cellular process you are interested
in and
this time point is mostly a structural
change that you would like to
analyze then on the on the en side
so the most important question you need
to ask yourself is how
stable is this particular stage
that you are interesting is in and for
the majority of the applications
that we are aiming um with this workflow
or addressing with this workflow um
zero two three or five seconds is
not so um relevant however if you have
something
fast uh for example as i said this
tracking
um trafficking um
um yeah the trafficking um topics
these can a little bit more tricky and
there we have to look in
in detail um with the users what they
like to
achieve in the workflow
all right thank you again dr kernick our
last question is
do you have additional information or
videos
um yes we prepared uh
tons of material um that we will release
within the next
weeks so we have um different
application notes uh that gives you more
um
depth of knowledge on on the
physiological control of the samples why
is this important
and how the the sampling chamber is
designed
we have an application note on the
imaging part
that explains a little bit more deeper
how um
how the sapphire corrected objective
works um why we developed this and shows
you more examples
uh on different samples how the the
quality looks like
and we have a a very detailed workflow
protocol that
shows on an example um how we did the
experiment
how much cells we seeded how we coded
the samples
how we processed them how we cut them
and and all these
types furthermore there's a workflow
protocol that
gives you a step-by-step description
throughout
what you have to do on the technical
side
and for this workflow protocol we also
created a lot of videos that explain
more or less
every step that we described in the
manual also in the video
and this will be then also available via
the website
or later also on you on youtube and um
yeah
you can um find them then um
everything is then on the website and
you get also the notifications
in the newsletter
well thank you dr kernig do you have any
final comments for our audience today
yes i would like to thank everybody who
joined the webinar today
it was a pleasure for me um to
show you our new solution and answer all
your questions
and yeah if you have more questions
reach out to your regional
leica contact and we're looking forward
to hear from you
thank you again excuse me dr kernick for
your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank labyrinth and our
sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye